this is a production of cornell
university
so i really appreciate your being here
some of you are aware that i'm retiring
in june and so this is something of a
retrospective seminar i have been a
senior extension associate and a senior
lecturer here in horticulture and
this feels like self-indulgence to me i
have not given a presentation like this
in a while i don't tend to lecture when
i'm teaching haven't used powerpoint
much
so to have a seminar that focuses on me
and my story has made me a little
anxious i must admit at the same time
it's been a real pleasure to spend some
time with reflection and when carlin so
generously reached out to me back in
january and asked if i would do this my
first inner reaction was kind of a groan
and then i thought this is really an
opportunity this is going to be a lot of
fun and here are some of the questions
that i found myself thinking about what
drew me to horticulture what are the
primary elements of my story and what
are its chapter titles
who were the great influencers you know
those people in our lives that are so
important
and as i'm preparing for this vital task
of moving on what does that look like
what kind of footprint do i want to
leave so it has been a really sweet time
of reflection and i'm again appreciative
for the opportunity
so i'll just begin with a chapter one
the early days here i grew up in a
working class family
and my brother and i were the first to
go to college and i was pretty clueless
i really didn't know what i was doing i
had a really inspiring high school
biology teacher steve austin who um if
he hadn't been teaching biology i
probably would be in whatever field he
had
taught at that time but i decided to
major in biology and because my high
school guidance counselor encouraged me
to apply to russell sage college i did
and i ended up going there because i got
the biggest financial aid package it
cost me 500 to go to russell sage but it
was also a private women's college in an
urban area i grew up in a working-class
family in a in a
in an urban area and i grew up in a
rural area and it was a shock it was not
such a good fit i just found myself a
little bit lost there even as
academically it was fine and one
february day i thought i've got to
figure this thing out this is not it's
just not a really good fit so i went for
a long walk
um and thought on this walk i'm gonna
figure out what comes next
and so i have to stumble into a flower
shop filled with plants filled with
greenery and i looked around and said
all right this will work
walk back
walked into my advisor's office and said
i want to transfer to a college that has
horticulture and that was it
based on that one flash of insight i
sometimes wonder if i hadn't walked down
that block what would have happened and
he said you know there's only one
institution for you and i applied to
cornell and wow felt like it was a sense
of homecoming i was in then a tiny
iteration of what is now horticulture
called flora culture and ornamental
horticulture and um and felt found my
home found my happy place loved the
university loved my major the people
dr robert maurer was my advisor and uh
just felt really cared for here and
at the first party that i went to and we
went to a lot of parties i met my
beloved um scott who's here my husband
he was then my best friend and later
we got married and so that was again
another fortuitous
moment on the cornell campus i did take
a year off and spend it in olympic
national park worked out there what we
now call a gap year we didn't have that
language then but just actually ran out
of money i put myself through school
thought i'd better slow things down took
a gap year and spent it out there and
then came back for my senior year had a
wonderful senior year i had an
individual study project i actually
wrote the first guide to sustainable
agriculture resources at cornell it was
then a new thing this would have been in
like 1982
and um
and
really enjoyed it and i had a great job
at the center for local food and
agriculture and this guy and this image
is was my supervisor he was a graduate
student he was a really caring
supervisor anybody recognize him he's in
this room
that's craig cramer oh
so craig and i craig and i go that far
back he was my my supervisor he would
loop around later his wife delivered one
of our children and then later again
when he came back as a um as when he
came in as a communication specialist so
craig and i have been working together
for some time
when i graduated we moved to saratoga
for
scott's job and i got a call one day
through a connection that he had
somebody said
susan bibi an extension educator here is
going for six months on maternity leave
how would you like to fill her position
and i said i'd love to ended up being
there for three years i at that time i
had three things some of you know in
cooperative extension you're often
juggling i'm looking at one person who
knows that really well here in the
audience i was in 4-h plant science i
worked with all of the commercial fruit
growers and also manage the master
gardener volunteer program so that was
wonderful because i got a little bit of
a taste of everything i was there about
again about three years and at that time
marvin pritz and i actually started
working the same year we started working
in
1984 and he would come up and meet with
the fruit growers and
at the end of that period of time he
said you know i have a position here as
a technician if you're interested so we
packed up and moved to uh back to ithaca
and that would begin chapter two berry
crops and children's gardens
so i worked as marvin's technician for
three years another three-year stint
there you see marvin with some pretty
short shorts there in the
and on the far end of that line looking
looking pretty pretty short there are
you in that picture i am i'm right in
the middle i'm actually right i'm right
here i know and you know what's really
funny we were talking about this
yesterday look at allison i don't know
how many of you know marvin's wife
she looks photoshopped in she's not
changed a bit she looks exactly like
that now
so i worked for three years at the
cornell orchards primarily caring for
marvin's research plots at a point at
which he was so active
that it was like being a commercial
grower and that was one of the benefits
of this time i remember thinking if i
needed to grow commercially i could
there were so much girl we actually
planted blueberry hill during that time
again dating myself wildly there
but
i also discovered that much as i
really appreciated the opportunity
research maybe wasn't my inclination and
marvin really recognized this started
inviting me to do more and more of his
extension presentations and then at the
end of this time period another position
opened up in what was then another
iteration of horticulture and i was
invited to take it and it was in the
children's garden arena it was then
called 4-h plant science so i slid into
another position there and spent the 90s
decade really enjoying working in the
area of a lot of extension visits a lot
of workshops actively engaged with the
american hort society
doing a lot of publications and
educational resource development really
starting to feel like i'm really finding
my niche here i i love that time period
i've got a little icon in the lower left
to remind me
to mention epcot
there was a an exciting project five of
us who were considered
children's gardening experts from around
the nation were invited to come to epcot
and design the model children's garden
which was a fascinating process and what
fascinated me as much as this children's
garden that we were developing was that
the woman who facilitated this design
charette was really good at what she did
and that's when i started noticing the
difference between giving a talk
and facilitating a workshop i actually
got in touch with her and said how do
you do what you do it was so seamless
and i think the seeds of facilitation
were planted there
incidentally that's that's our son jacob
who
is in the lower uh right hand corner
with his friend out in the conservatory
he's actually on the zoom call now
give a shout out to him for joining us
he's now 32 so he's changed a bit since
then too
and at the end of that decade i went
back for graduate study and in community
development and education and
came back to the department in a new
role as a senior extension associate
later i would add or add being a senior
lecturer
and laurie brewer we hired her she was
then lori bushway and
just developed a lifelong friendship in
her and we we changed 4-h plant science
from
now calling it cornell garden-based
learning which seemed more inclusive of
the work we did by the way if you
haven't seen lori in a while she is
thriving and healthy and
that's actually a current picture of her
in the lower right and she is ringing
the bell you can't see the bell she's
just completed the saranac six
hikes in the adirondacks some of you are
not and you're familiar with that so we
just it was just such a joy to work with
lori
and and that really began then the next
chapter which i've titled creative
possibilities i felt as if i just had
this brain explosion around the
possibilities
in exciting an interest
in people in in our amazing discipline
finding all these different avenues for
engaging people in horticulture things
that maybe we hadn't done before such as
the art of horticulture course
and uh just really trying to think of
ways in for people who might not think
about our discipline but wanting to
engage them and it was just it i think
of this time as just this kind of brain
explosion doing a lot of projects on
campus
and also really starting to engage in a
number of collaborations with people
there's frank in the upper right he's
here in the room today for those of you
who are on zoom
we designed a number of sod sofas here
on campus we did them in our extension
system as well and just had so much fun
engaging in living sculpture as a
imagine that you haven't learned about
grass and you get to do it by building
assad sofa just just such a joy
also developed a series of distance
courses including three distance courses
and botanical illustration
who i've passed the torch to sonja
williams she's not now teaching them
again thank you shout out to sonya who
is on our zoom call today with us and um
another uh
course in introduction to garden design
so stirring is starting to stir a number
of pots here teaching on campus distance
learning and then of course an extension
program
and you can just see these amazing works
of art created by students what what a
what a pleasure there's also a funny
story from this time
it was i remember again just having this
sense of brain fever like all these
ideas about ways to excite an interest
in horticulture and i flew into bill
miller's office at that time we were
engaged in a
bulb project with the dutch growers and
went into bill miller's office and said
bill bill here's this thing we've got to
do it would be so much fun to uh plant a
big bulb labyrinth like this giant bulb
labyrinth like just imagine how
beautiful it would be and if you know
bill he was sitting there just
looking at me
just kind of looking at me and i'm like
can you picture it like a ball blabber
and his ball labyrinth huh
bob lambron okay you're talking about a
bulb labyrinth right so he picks up the
phone and calls ron white who was then
the manager at bluegrass lane hey ron i
got to tell you something funny okay i
got to tell you i got marsha ian shively
sitting here in my office you know what
a pain in the ass she is right
okay well get this
here's what she's talking about she's
talking about building a bulb
labyrinth i know i know he's laughing
and i'm starting to feel so
incredibly embarrassed
the next thing he said was where do you
think we could sight this thing
so here's another beautiful project
actually builded this with his students
you can see him he's there in the upper
right
um and you can see this image in the
left or the right side upper left is
bill on the right side of the screen
you'll see christine haddickle
frolicking through that bob labyrinth
she's somebody that worked in our
program for a really short period of
time but had an incredibly big impact
you'll be seeing some more images of her
again a period of a lot of activity and
extension here are you know just a
handful of the projects that we did with
young people trying to think about
different ways in
dig art cultivating creativity in the
garden this was one that christine
developed living sculpture discovering
our food system youth grow and all sorts
of ways in for young people to
experience horticulture
also engaged with a research project
around 2006 to 2008
which involved looking at the power
dynamics between young people and adults
and one of the findings from that time
which was fascinating to us is there is
no correlation between gardening
activity
and an interest in gardening among young
people the correlation is between um and
in between decision making and an
interest in gardening so if you want to
excite an interest in young people
you're better off engaging them in the
process you can garden all summer with
them and tell them how to weed and water
in fact you might kill their interest so
this was pretty exciting news to us
went on to teach a host of courses i
don't even know if this is a complete
list
kept leah really busy with the 49 40
courses
and
again just so much joy in the work of
teaching i included graduate teaching
experience because i came to think of
our graduate students as teaching
apprentices put a lot of energy into
working closely with them and spending
time with them meeting weekly and
talking about the craft of teaching and
learning
so much joy
also went through a period of applying
for and receiving funds from the cornell
council for the arts for doing a number
of projects here on campus
this is a gandhi and grass exhibit that
was in the frank is laughing was in the
mann library foyer what a wild thing we
i sometimes think we had a lot of nerve
you know we just had this idea of
creating this huge 12 by 12 by 12
black velvet box
and projecting an image of gandhi on a
huge panel of grass with the idea that
it would burn in and we had peep holes
people could watch the process it worked
okay we kind of petted the grass in
different directions to make it work
there's christine haddickle there again
in the in the lower left of the right
hand panel another project she was
involved with we had rooted out on the
um on live slope in bulbs and brought
patrick doherty to campus for
a week of messenger lectures and then
doing a huge willow sculpture at ithaca
children's garden
also another one of christine's
influences was
encouraging a partnership in southern
belize and i would go down there seven
times with students to teach there a
number of courses mostly focused around
experiential garden-based learning in
belize but not limited to that we also
had a tropical plants extravaganza and
another number of other
courses but that just proved to be such
a rich partnership
really struck up a strong partnership
with plenty belize there and it was a
model that was based on mentoring
this is we had and here just a few of
them we had many mentors from
cooperative extension from campus in the
community that
came on these trips so that i i would be
spending my time managing the students
and the partnership and they would
provide student support and their
content expertise as well
you'll see some familiar faces marvin
and leah there's fiona doherty grant
thompson charles malone and cooperative
extension elizabeth gabriel and
christine hadachal and up at the top on
the zip line is abib palma he is
somebody that we worked there every time
we went and uh so we worked hard and
played hard we we had one day that we
would spend doing something like going
to the caves or a zip line or something
like that it was just such a rich time
in fact uh i would say one of my
favorite courses that i ever taught was
a course called healing plants and the
people who use them
and the way it came about was that our
partner there said we have six shaman
who
are very worried about passing along
their
knowledge to people and they what they
would like to do is to work with your
students to document their plants in
english and latin
so that they have it for their record
because they're worried about losing
this so we ended up it's so funny i got
funding and then started to write the
syllabus and realize i actually don't
know a lot about this topic so i invited
three graduate students in anthropology
plant biology and horticulture and they
provided again the mentoring and the
support and also
a deep content expertise and we ended up
with a big focus on healing we included
hearthstone herbal school and our
preparation and one of the students even
went so far as to say whoops i say i
never thought that the um
uh the healing that would happen in this
course would be my own it was such a
powerful powerful experience
by the way i didn't say at the beginning
this is going to be about no more than
about half an hour and then i'm going to
turn it over to you and we'll have a
conversation not going to be talking
that much longer
so
chapter four this brings us to chapter
four courage and renewal
um
at a point in the 2000s and the early to
mid 2000s our hearts broke and this is
something that happens to every human
being that i have ever known
we encountered some family patterns that
were challenging even some generational
trauma
stuff we needed to deal with and it was
a really really hard time
one of our sons also had um
his best friend since babyhood died and
that was shattering and then not long
after that three of our remaining
parents died within a little more than a
year from of one another and it was it
was so hard and i'm looking at you and
guessing that some of you know what that
is in whatever way that you've
experienced difficulty and if you don't
know what i mean then i'll reassure you
that you'll have your moment it happens
as a human being on this earth and i i
am so grateful for the various kinds of
support from that time but one of them
was
parker j palmer's work parker palmer is
an educator author and activist
i had practically memorized one of his
books it's called the heart of higher
education also read the courage to teach
let your life speak healing the heart of
democracy and along in that time period
i had an opportunity to be on retreat
with him it was through what is now the
einhorn center it was when we had this
big gift coming to the university and
and the number of folks in central
administration wanted to pull some
people together to reflect together but
do it in a way that was spacious and
heart-centered and due to a connection
with the einhorns parker agreed to come
and give a university retreat he would
do another one later on and within 15
minutes of being in that room i was
thinking this is something different i
don't know what this is but i want more
of it it was just so different
and he used language like um which
really rung true with me at that time he
said you know all of our hearts are
going to break
and the heart that is brittle will
shatter
but the heart that is supple expands and
we grow larger from our difficulty i
thought i want more of that so i went to
a number of these programs and would
eventually prepare is about a three-year
process as a circle of trust facilitator
prepared by the center for courage and
renewal it's been life-changing i've
integrated it into pretty much
everything that i do
their tagline is nurturing deep
integrity and relational trust building
the foundation for a more loving
equitable and healthy world and to
engage in that kind of wholehearted work
in the workplace was really really
exciting to me
i would go on then to
develop an inner life of teaching and
leadership
opportunity it's a cohort building
experience for faculty and staff
across the university here on our campus
i led that six times it's now in the
capable hands of other people as i
prepare to go and
again just found it to be really
life-altering work some of you picked up
the handouts some of you on zoom got
them electronically
and you'll see that there are
touchstones for how we engage with one
another and there's the practice of
asking and open on it asking open and
honest questions that's bedrock to this
work as is the use of some unusual
perhaps for some teaching devices in our
work
such as poetry wisdom stories and other
things that help us to drop from our
analytical minds into our hearts and
bodies you'll see i included a poem on
aging which uh really spoke to me
offering a different way of thinking
about eldering here at the university so
again if you have an opportunity to read
those you might another time
i don't think it's a coincidence that
because of my own incredible
deep mentoring experience i was actually
assigned a mentor and i worked with her
for two years i actually went through a
grieving process when it was over put
more energy into that than i did my
graduate study by a mile
that because of the influence i became
interested in mentoring initiatives
started the pure
the plant science peer mentoring program
here in the plant sciences
and also worked with mike bishop and sue
merkel to begin a mentoring initiative
across the university
uh i've been working recently with
sophia lloyd and nishi dupa
for developing a woman of color a
mentoring initiative at cornell one of
our elephants is the in the room is that
women of color do not stay at cornell
i have been heartbroken at the number of
colleagues who have left and so this was
in response to this to think if we had a
mentoring initiative that was supportive
and provide a deep connection
might we support better these women of
color we've just launched that uh
starting uh this month actually or in
february and and we're so hopeful that
it might make a difference and then
again informal mentoring formal
mentoring i'm on mentor mentoring
committees and a number of people i've
met through the inner life cohort have
invited more of that kind of
conversation and
as an elder um as somebody late career
i've really welcomed it
another thing that courage and renewal
programs gave me the courage to do was
to look at the wounds of um of whiteness
healing the wounds of whiteness the
inner work of facing racism i would not
have had the courage to engage in that
work without the ballast of the
background of um courage and renewal and
again i've worked closely with people in
recent years such as eduardo gonzalez
and our and our extension system my very
dear friend jamila walida simon
one of the things i've learned from them
that i really want to name is there's
something amazing about the way and some
of you here were at the soulfire farm
workshop that we hosted
about the way in which they hold the
gravitas
of the work
with kind of joy and relief of working
together putting our shoulders into it i
always end up feeling better after i've
worked with them like it's not a grim
duty it's it's a joy to be in it
together and i've appreciated that
worked closely with anna bartell in the
einhorn center doing things like we
we've
been engaged in work such as presenting
a fumbling toward equity panel for the
inclusive
excellence summit um
and uh working with violet and anu on a
reconnecting with purpose initiative for
farm and food system change makers a
retreat series that bookends peer
learning circles working with malina
ivanchakova who is in the upper left
of this
zoom shot on teaching and learning in
the diverse classroom this past summer
again i i don't know that i would have
found my way into this work and felt
grounded enough to engage in it without
the work of courage and renewal
and speaking of collaboration i have to
name
the joy of working with lori
lori and ashley who are here in this
room today in cornell garden-based
learning ashley and i co-lead cornell
garden-based learning lori is a staff
member that we've hired who has just
completed the most exciting
project so seeds of wonder food
gardening with justice and mind
curriculum we're just we're very excited
about that so
wonderful colleagues
so i'm going to pause here briefly
before drawing to a close and just name
some patterns that i want to speak to
in putting this together i think i'm a
pattern seeker and found myself just
reflecting on what am i noticing in all
of these images well for one thing i'm
noticing there's so much beauty there's
so much beauty in these slides they're
just gorgeous i mean the faces of people
and the work that we've done and
what a beautiful what a privilege to
work in this discipline
i'm
also pretty staggered by the
collaborations i mean i've known that
i've been inclined in that direction
but to see them all all of these again
wonderful faces and and the joy in
working together it's been it's really
been a pleasure to to witness that and
to pick that out as a pattern another
pattern that i would name i don't know
if you noticed
but i didn't apply for anything
and i just find that very interesting
i've kind of stumbled i mean i was
invited to go to the first college
and i was invited to come to cornell and
i was invited to you know it was it's a
really fascinating thing to feel like
kind of right place in the right time
and saying okay that sounds good walking
down a street horticulture sounds good
you know it's really interesting to me
there's another pattern that i want to
name and in january somebody told me
about the work of catherine price who
is a researcher who studies fun an f
word we don't use at the university very
much
and she has found that in her research
there are three primary components of
fun that she would name that are are
central to
enjoyment
one is a sense of playfulness and
lightheartedness
two is a powerful sense of connection
with others and three is a sense of flow
of being in the flow
and and does that ever characterize a
number of the things that i've shared
with you these are students in our seed
to supper class yes having fun over in
the pounders garden as they're learning
so it has been a joy it's been a lot of
fun
we don't always talk about that but
important to name
so with that i'm going to start drawing
to a close chapter 5 the sunrise after
the sunset what comes next after being
if i count the time i was an
undergraduate i've been here 43 years i
took a year in the olympic mountains and
uh three years in saratoga but that's a
long time to be in one place so what
comes next
um for one thing i am eager to spend
time in my garden i've been a
garden-based learning educator my whole
life
and i do gardening on the weekends like
a weekend warrior so i am really eager
to know you know what it is to get up on
a wednesday morning and not have that
sense of of um you know the pressure of
like
7 30 is coming my way and it's time to
go to work this is actually what our
garden will look like oh gosh maybe
about three or four weeks there to the
left and uh on the right you'll see a
salad harvested scott build a hoop house
i was ready to marry him all over again
after that and um this is a late season
salad from our hoop house yes that's a
fig in there too really eager to do more
of this
um
i'm i'm an artist and uh
you know just spending more spacious
time painting in recent years i've
really gotten into botanical eco
printing and i'm actually selling these
you can see these silk scarves uh
to wallow in it again not have that
feeling of like something i have to pack
in on a weeknight or a weekend i'm
definitely going to be doing more with
courage and renewal programs possibly
here but definitely outside the
university as well
and i'm going to take a leap here in a
as soon as the application process opens
for 2023
to apply to an eco chaplaincy program i
saw it online and i felt this like
ripple of recognition go through me it's
13 months long it has a week or maybe
eight day residency and you can see
environment environmentally based
spiritual care i look at those words and
man my heart starts beating faster the
histories of environmentalism
the skills around spiritual counseling
nature based ritual more than human
storytelling i don't know what that is
but i want to find out
what really i find compelling is
practices rituals and ceremonies for
ministering ecological death dying grief
and loss you know we talk about climate
change and we think about the science
around preparing for that but sometimes
we don't talk about the profound
grieving and loss that people feel and
we also don't talk that much about the
roots of it which are things like greed
and apathy and ignorance and
and too much wanting and too much
looking for convenience and i you know
want to look in my own heart there
around those things so i'm quite excited
about this
cross your fingers that i get accepted
so i want to close with um here's what
we'll do
i want to offer some gratitude of course
i have to have some questions for
reflections for you look at students who
know that really well of course you
would expect that and then we'll chat
for a little bit and then about 10
minutes after i have a three minute
video that i'd like to show before we go
out it will be about a project called
turf work that we did
out it's a more it was a more than one
acre-sized piece of earth art that we
did out at bluegrass lane another rossy
collaboration there so we'll close with
that
so how do you offer gratitudes for 38
years of work there's no way that i
could do that without leaving anyone out
but i just want to say briefly there is
no way
no way that i could have done
what i've done in terms of it being kind
of an unconventional approach to
horticulture without supportive
leadership there's no way
in another horticulture department i i
kind of don't think so i don't see that
happening elsewhere i don't think it
would even happen in other departments
here that kind of openness to yeah that
sounds good are you serious did you hear
me
are you sure you know what i what i'm
hoping to do here so i want to
acknowledge you know marvin in
particular and then steve and justine
who have followed and really upheld that
same spirit of openness
i i want to acknowledge my
incredible colleagues all across the
university and in our extension system
and our amazing students we are so lucky
to do the work that we do here as well
as i want to name the inner life cohort
participants a real rich it's a way of
getting to know people all from across
the university it's been such a joy
i would i don't want to go down the
dangerous path of mentioning particular
people because i might leave somebody
out but there are three that i have to
mention i mean i
want to acknowledge my husband scott
and i want to name our kids jake and
will who have been just again champions
and supporters and enthusiasts of this
work and i'm so grateful again not
something that everybody gets to enjoy
that kind of support i want to
acknowledge craig kramer all of those
beautiful images or many of them
because he shows up and takes shots of
our work
uh it's a
and it's so much fun i mean
a lot again a lot of people don't have
that gift and i certainly want to
acknowledge marvin i quite literally
wouldn't be standing here for one thing
without his invitation and i've also
come to think of him he's my brother
from another mother
and really appreciate we've had a had a
long long co-creative career together so
so much to be grateful for so much
gratitude
so with that i'm going to pause
take a breath it's the longest i've
talked for quite a long time
and these um they're not showing up real
well on that screen it looks like you
can see them they're good so i i would
invite you to think about what drew you
to horticulture
what are the primary elements of your
story and what are what would you call
your chapter titles it's been fun
thinking about this
who are your great influencers it's so
helpful to pause periodically and think
again for me all the way back to my
parents who instilled the love of
gardening in me and my high school
biology teacher who were who were they
for you
and if you are late career as i am i'm
like very late career
as you prepare for the vital task of
moving on what does that look like how
do you age with wisdom and courage and
grace and you know what comes next for
you what kind of footprint do you want
to leave behind
so i will just open it up for comments
and questions for if this has triggered
something in you that you might want to
share
then i'd invite that again we've got a
lovely five minutes or so here and just
welcome anything that you would like to
offer
and thank you if you've been hanging in
on zoom really really appreciate your
being with us here today finally gotten
in the habit of um of giving you eye
contact appreciating that you're you're
here with us any questions comments
reflections on your own experience yeah
can you speak more about the circle of
trust activity that you mentioned like
what it does like how to implement that
so the circle of trust methodology is
characterized by um
uh
it's it's literally a circle if it's in
person and there are small group
individual reflection and large group
reflection around things that are
important to us as people
so um for example there are
circles that explore um
leadership through the lens of what is
it like to draw on our inner selves as
we are who do we who are we as leaders
on the inside and how do our core values
inform our work
there might be circles around aging one
of the things i'm really interested in
is a circle approach to
um
it's a dream i'm confiding and i'm
realizing confiding in a large group of
people is a funny thing to do but i'm
curious about working with aging faculty
around the question of
who am i now and who am i becoming and
having opportunities to meet with others
over imagine a three day period and then
meeting monthly and peer learning
circles with a closing opportunity so
one of the things that circles of trust
and again it's character we communicate
with one another in a certain way it's
confidential we don't give advice to one
another
but it really often opens up something
in us that was unexpected and we're in a
space in which that's invited it's
probably the best thing i could say
marvin you were in it you want to say
anything about your experience in it
i think the best thing about it is we
have very few venues at the university
to talk about things other than our
your research or sometimes our teaching
even then sometimes it's questionable
this is a place where you can go and
just talk about what you've been
thinking about what's inside you hearing
from other people's you know
what
they want to see their promises their
best aspirations
and so
that and we just don't have a venue like
that so that's why it's really i think
valuable to get together with people
that you don't necessarily know and talk
about this thing you find out you have a
lot in common with other people
that you all have these inner desires to
kind of break out of your
shell and uh
i'll fight with the question you talked
about perjury newell sort of at the end
but i've seen you have courage from the
very beginning
and to break out and push the boundaries
and the parameters were sometimes locked
into with our academic
programs our rigor and all that so
i guess my question is what words of
advice do you have to people here
to kind of go beyond that comfort zone
in an academic environment and push the
limits of it because i know everybody
here probably
has a
little bit of creativity or that desire
to
do something a little bit different but
we feel constrained sometimes by the
culture and all do you have any advice
or how how did you get that courage from
the very beginning to like keep pushing
the limits
so thank you marvin and for those of you
who are on zoom i don't know if you
could hear marvin i'll just reiterate
briefly by he was talking they could
hear fine
okay great great um
that's also buying me a little time to
think about an answer
um on a given thing
on a given day of course we would answer
a question differently right but what's
coming to my right mind right now and i
will trust it is of all things a cornell
leadership opportunity we had a 360
where you get 360 feedback and i was
sitting down with a coach who was gonna
give at 360. that means people
that i've invited my colleagues
my supervisor you know people were
giving me um
feedback and then you sit down it's kind
of tender you're receiving open and
honest feedback
but what the coach said to me was
you have tremendous personal power
i think you should use it
and i think it planted in me
and i probably used it before then
because this wasn't until the mid you
know it was in the 2000s but i guess in
terms of
guidance i would say
we all have
personal authority
we all have inner authority
uh it isn't dependent on our positions
i've done a lot as a non-tenure track
faculty member and i think it's from
drawing on that sense of i think
connecting with our interior what am i
about what do i believe in
and
having that give me the courage to speak
up and to do
what i am here to do
you know in a way another way of looking
at it if you have gifts that you and you
alone have in this world and you don't
use them
you know what is that i think there
could be tremendous regret at the end of
our lives
so i think it's what we're here for i
mean tomorrow i might answer that
differently but trust yourselves align
yourselves with the people who foster
that trust in you that's another thing
you asked about courage and renewal you
know there's a lot it's a it's a
trustworthy space where you are
connecting with your inner gifts it is
never about naval gazing or you know the
sort of me and myself absorbed it's like
you get your ballast so you can get back
out there to do the work that you are
meant to do that's how i'd answer that
now maybe maybe one more question or
comment if this stirred something up in
you that you want to just
name about your own
interest in horticulture your own
passion for it
what brought you here
anything else
yes jonah um as you
look into this eco chaplain work
um
it definitely to me feels like something
that makes a lot of sense for you what
are what are you
drawing from specifically as you prepare
to maybe enter that chapter do you have
any
specific models or or inspirations that
you're thinking of because to me it
reminds me very much of like what rondas
did
um in hospice you know being sort of a
guide for people
um trying to reconcile with some of the
deepest
questions we face so i'm wondering what
what you're drawing from there
you know if i'm really honest i don't
know yet i have a very dear friend it's
someone who's actually on the zoom call
that once went through a similar program
and i said what are you going to do with
it she said i don't know in fact she
might have said something like i'm
surprised you would ask me that now i
know what she means i don't know jonah i
guess that's another response to
marvin's question is i i am i trust my
intuition
and uh and again i trust that ripple
that went through my body when i
when i saw that description and thought
that is the next step for me
and and i don't fully know and you know
i feel like all the markers are leading
in this direction i think we're one
thing we're all going to die
and i think it could be helpful to have
a
skill set and being present to people
that i love
as we age and and
head in that direction so that's another
thing but
um i don't really fully know yet
it's a wonderful question thank you
well i'm
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu